[Music]
i was just worried about
babies is that a child in vegas yes um
i've seen a few of them now
a beloved canadian actress all of canada
is obsessed with you so including myself
so thank you so much
and a real-time red carpet switch roof
oh let's switch arou
it's a jam-packed night in vegas for
cinemacon my dad was on set with us
giving de niro notes on how to be a
hairdresser so on a scale of one to ten
how are robert de niro's hair styling
skills now that your dad taught him
based on what i saw in the movie he's
pretty dead on oh really so i was just
talking to sebastian and he said you
were amazing at highlighting hair that
you really nailed his dad's skills
oh nice okay well that's good that's
nice something to say
what is the first day like on set when
robert de niro walks in when bob came to
set
i was shaking and then i just covered it
with like an over exuberance
so then i was like stalkery with bob
i suddenly became like hi bob how are
you hi bob how are you what are you
doing what are you doing like
what are you most excited for the fans
to see when it comes to john wick 4. to
see what this gentleman this maestro
this mad genius has
cooked up and given us the opportunity
to do we have some amazing john wick
action and new characters okay so now
we're backstage at cinemacon's big
screen achievement awards where i just
happen to run into glenn powell billy
eichner and zoe saldana i need your help
[Music]
people freaked out you know at cinemacon
we got to see the first footage of
avatar how excited are you i mean i'm
kind of jealous that you got to see it
before i did but um that tends to be the
case it's okay i did see 20 minutes of a
very rough cut of the ending
and i was so deeply moved that i
couldn't even utter any words and when
it comes to the legendary director james
cameron no nicknames allowed morgan
that's jimbo i'm not cool enough to calm
jimbo you can't i wasn't even cool
enough jim am i cool to call you jimbo
it's epic it's awesome it's like
one of the coolest movies i think you
can experience with other people
what the hell
good morning aviators i actually
realized on this movie tom cruise is
maverick
this is your captain speaking he is
maverick i was like oh this guy will
never slow down no he is
a daredevil beyond belief he is focused
he's as cool as you think he is it's
very cool to have maverick in your phone
that's awesome yeah
well that's it for me from vegas thank
you so much to caesars palace for having
us i'm totally going to jump into that
pool right after this you can head over
to etcanada.com for all the latest back
to you guys in studio yeah you get in
that pool such great work this week so
many great interviews especially the one
with rachel mcadams